wo ist dein leben
[Musik]
hey was tut mir leid was soll das warum
antwortest du mir nicht ich habe dir
geschrieben ich angerufen und das habe
ich gesehen
ich verstehe einfach nicht was los ist
entweder du sagst mir warum du mir nicht
antwort ist oder ich bleib den ganzen
tag hier vor deinem haus stehen wovon
sprichst du ich will einfach nicht dass
es irgendwelche missverständnisse
zwischen uns gibt habe ich was falsches
gesagt nico ich war es entweder wir
treffen uns heimlich in der wg oder in
der stadt aber aber ich muss und ich
sehen deshalb bin ich gekommen
du hast nichts falsch gemacht es hat
nichts mit dir zu tun
wir dürfen uns nicht treffen nico meine
eltern es nicht ich weiß aber ich kann
nicht mehr lügen nico ich fühle mich so
so unglaublich schlecht gerade jetzt
meine eltern dürfen sich jetzt nicht
aufregend aber was ist denn passiert
mein vater ist wieder im krankenhaus
was er hatte einen herzen für muster
versorgt werden es tut mir leid das ist
nicht seine schuld
es tut mir leid nico